[Music]
i don't like my mind right now
stacking up problems that is so
unnecessary wish that i could slow
things down
i want to let go but discomfort in the
panic
and i drive myself crazy thinking
everything's about me
yeah i drive myself crazy cause i can't
escape the gravity
[Music]
so much more than i can carry
i keep dragging around what's
[Music]
but i'm pretty sure the part is out to
get me it's not like i made the choice
so let my mind stay so [\h__\h] messy
i know i'm not the center of the
universe but you keep
is
[Music]
if i just let go
is
[Music]
myself crazy
so much more than i can carry
i keep
[Music]
is
hey there friends so um clearly i was
working through some stuff this day in
the studio and um
you know at the time i was doing it i
was just
kind of expressing some stuff that had
come up for me the week leading up to uh
that studio appointment
and afterwards looking at it i realized
that something kind of special had
happened and it's really really rare
that i capture
flow that i feel like is really an
exemplary example of
the things that i've been doing to try
and bring more emotion into my boy
dancing
absolutely everything you just saw was
improvised on the spot there's like one
little piece of it where i take a small
bit of um choreo that
i had sitting around and i inserted it
in at one spot other than that
absolutely all of that was improvised on
the spot
um so it felt like something that i was
proud enough of that i wanted to share
with you all so i hope you enjoyed it
um
but i do need to put some thank yous out
there uh starting with the friends of
the channel big thanks to
dark monk flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroterra lightweights spin
balls and ultra poi for helping to make
the videos on this channel possible you
can learn more about all these amazing
companies and work that they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that i've got
down in the description of this video uh
and a special thanks to the first
non-business friends of the channel that
is johnny howard lane machinski and
becca
thank you one and all for your support
for my mission and uh for those of you
out there that are wondering no this
video was not sponsored it was just
something i was proud of and wanted to
share with all of you
but more thanks for on the way because
this video would not be possible without
the kind support of all of these
wonderful people over here these are my
flow patrons and they along with people
listed down in the description help to
make this video and all the videos on my
channel possible
if you'd like to help me out in my
mission and bring boy spinning and flow
arts to the wider world and helping
people connect with their brains and
their bodies i could definitely use it
uh you can do that by heading on over to
patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up
there uh you can get access to a whole
host of rewards
uh including things like early access to
my content or being able to get a
special private lesson that is delivered
only
to supporters of my channel on patreon
so go check that out please and thank
you
um
as you might be able to tell this one
was really personal and there's a lot
that came out in the course of it and in
some ways it feels
very vulnerable sharing it with the
wider world and in other ways um
i'm kind of looking at him being like
that's exactly what it should be so
y'all can tell me what you think of it
uh
leave a comment and let me know and uh
hopefully this is something that is
appreciated by any of you out there i'll
go ahead and leave a link to some
additional videos that i've done showing
off flow sessions uh a playlist of them
down in the description or up on the
screen
if you happen to be watching this video
on youtube i hope you're able to get out
and get in some flow today and i'll see
you with a new video on wednesday thanks
again
peace